sirvas de ver todo el vídeo antes de
revisar la circulación sanguínea en su
brazo
este video le enseñará Cómo revisar la
circulación sanguínea en su brazo
una buena circulación sanguínea es
importante para la recuperación después
del procedimiento quirúrgico de su brazo
paso 1 revise la mano y los dedos del
brazo que se está recuperando del
procedimiento quirúrgico
compare sus brazos nota alguna
diferencia
la mano y los dedos en el lado
quirúrgico deben estar tibios de color
normal y presentar poca o ninguna
hinchazón
estos signos significan que usted tiene
una buena circulación sanguínea en el
brazo si su mano se ve roja o Azul se
siente fría o está muy hinchada su brazo
puede tener mala circulación sanguínea
[Música]
paso 2 siente entumecimiento u hormigueo
en la mano
una sensación de entumecimiento u
hormigueo también puede ser síntomas de
mala circulación sanguínea o también
puede sentir el entumecimiento por un
tipo de anestesia llamada bloqueo de
nervio hasta que desaparezca su efecto
si no está seguro si le aplicaron un
bloqueo de nervio consulte con su
cirujano
paso 3 mueva los dedos mover los dedos
puede mejorar la circulación sanguínea
de su mano
repita los pasos 1 al 3 cada 4 horas o
según lo indicado por su cirujano
otra manera de comprobar si tiene una
buena circulación sanguínea es haciendo
la prueba del llenado capilar
los capilares son vasos sanguíneos
pequeños que llevan la sangre rica en
oxígeno hacia los dedos la prueba del
llenado capilar le permite ver que
también circula la sangre a través de
estos vasos sanguíneos hacia sus dedos
en el lado quirúrgico
paso 1 pellizque suavemente la punta del
dedo directamente sobre la uña con su
otra mano
[Música]
paso 2 pellizque hasta que la uña se
ponga blanca y luego suelte
la uña debe ponerse nuevamente rosada en
el lapso de dos o tres segundos este
signo significa que usted tiene una
buena circulación sanguínea en su brazo
y mano
repita los pasos 1 y 2 cada 4 horas o
según lo indicado por su cirujano
[Música]
comuníquese con su cirujano si nota que
su mano se ve roja o Azul se ve muy
hinchada se siente fría y entumecida o
con hormigueo A menos que le hayan
realizado un bloqueo de nervio durante
la cirugía lo que hace que su brazo se
sienta entumecido hasta que pase el
efecto o que su uña demore más de dos a
tres segundos en retornar a su color
rosado al hacer la prueba de llenado
capilar
[Música]